[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
andreas alors mon chéri questarabad
aujourd'hui dans son escarcelle plein de
trucs j'ai regardé la télé ce week end
un petit peu de youtube et j'ai un micro
trottoir pour la fin du mois de mai
contre doit alors un chevalet dans la
rue poser des questions en français et
vous savez ce que je fais tout le temps
je change la question on adore c'est le
lundi ça maintenant c'est le lundi et
j'adore j'ai un peu essoufflée j'ai
couru alors j'ai commencé mon ballon
justement c'est pour sa soirée avec
quelqu'un sur le chemin alors rappelez
vous il ya quelques temps sur youtube je
vous ai amené les images d'un coach en
développement personnel qui m'apprenez
un petit peu à mieux réussir dans la vie
il avait également un conseil c'était
d'avoir un regard un peu plus ténébreux
ce qui peut vous aider à réussir dans la
vie rappelez vous voir comment
transformer ce regard hoya justement
plus ténébreux donc petit compression
entre des jouets des sourcils
tu vois comme ça tu meurs
le fondateur du mouvement aérienne c'est
un concept spirituel censé vous pousser
vers l'excellence et la tenue à vous
adresser
justement des conseils un certain amour
envers ces pressions alors écoutez les
bien ses conseils parce qu'un jour ça
peut vous aider à décoller je dis ça je
dis rien partie your comment tu vas bien
tranquilles laure aujourd'hui vont
répondre à la question cruciale est ce
que cyril hanouna et d'un rien
au niveau de la voix malheureusement
c'est un point faible parce que c'est
génétique
on n'a pas la chance voilà de naître
avec tous une superbe voix col noir
au niveau du rire ça passe pas pour moi
sans quoi rire de ouistitis ya encore du
déchet c'est normal après au niveau de
la carrure ça s'est amélioré tu parles
beaucoup plus fort beaucoup plus large
mais malheureusement c'est de la grèce
bon je vous conseille pour tous de
prendre du muscle la jcat mots ce mot à
dire alfort respect est rien tu n'es pas
très loin de ta grandeur et c'est pour
ça que je te kiffe
allez ciao ciao bye bye mais c'est que
de la graisse jeu l'adorent semin cache
pas qu on a hésité quand on est en prada
le passé on sait donc qu'il me restait
qui veut partir il a passé l adore
muscle qui voit la vraie mois s'il adore
on embrasse
après ça j'ai regardé un petit peu le
sport était à ses yeux une horrible et
j'ai commencé justement avec la
conférence de presse de l'équipe de
france c'est avant tout à l'heure c'est
ça il avait une autre aussi vendredi
alors il ya que ça voilà alors longtemps
on sait que didier deschamps à l'oeil
pour choisir ses joueurs autant c'est
qu'il a beaucoup moins quand il s'agit
de repérer un journaliste à deux mètres
de lui c'est un peu relou au delà ici
aujourd'hui nul ici bonjour dit bonjour
didier thomas mikos foot365 bord et on
comprend pourquoi il a galéré à trouver
son interlocuteur c'est parce qu'il est
puni et à une caméra tout au fond thomas
microsoft ou 3 6 5 ou leur revenir sur
anthony martial comment vous jugez sa
trajectoire ces dernières années
tiens grand monsieur qui s'appelait
philippe tournon ouais c'est vrai je
comptais à l'accord devait choisir il
est bon celui de maintenant aussi ils
sont mous son sens pas mal à placer les
journalistes en mairie
c'est pas grand chose après ça j'ai
regardé monaco psg ce week-end à comme
vous le savez kimbembe le joueur de
paris a du mal à people mais ça va
quelles erreurs j'ai fait je sais tu me
plais bien du mal à marquer cette saison
se passe comme quoi le défenseur a du
mal à marquer cette saison c'est parce
qu'il a encore des petits problèmes de
précision
et c'est un peu chiant compte c'est qui
le joueur
notre cadreur vient de prendre un vilain
coup nous ça fait mal et sur l'équipe
c'est qu'il y ait une commentatrice un
peu trop fan de jean michel maire
c'était ça c'était ma manière de saluer
c'est le respect de l'adversaire mais
respect de l'arbitré du public de
larbitre et pour finir voici le papa qui
a misé 100 euros sur le match de son
fils et qui voulait absolument pas
perdre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était après journée de lutte en plus
les pommes et le pauvre petit aurait pu
faire bon c'est peut-être pour ça que
c'est toujours pas d'enfant
ouais après ça je suis passé voir pascal
praud ce matin sur cd alors on n'est que
lundi
tu es plutôt d'accord avec vous je te
tue sommes à l'antenne
je suis épuisé je peux juste rajouter
une chose non de 6 10 sur ce qu'il
aurait pu en faire quatre sur ce qui en
effet ne veut rien dire celles à venir à
ma place et août et alain ferrière
l'émission s'est initié il ya des faits
il ya des faits sur 20 sur les années
les plus chaudes
[Applaudissements]
c'est le cas de tuer plus à bah
justement vendredi soir je devienne en
boîte malheureusement le vigile
d'établissement c'est un petit peu
opposés à mon projet du coup je suis
rentré j'ai allumé s'est vite et devinez
quoi
j'ai vu au de ganache et ouais vendredi
soir d'ailleurs fait une ville d'aba
félicitations à ce qu'il aille bien
pompéi cité berceau s'est mis les
imitateurs des cris d'animaux excellent
cadeau et je crois qu'il va déflorer la
séquence c'est un petit peu ce que je
voulais vendre alors justement une
concept de l'émission s'était notamment
de recevoir des talents vous avez reçue
le vainqueur de l'ukraine au programme
talents ouais alors on s'attendait
justement à ce qu'ils les babas un
talent mais dans son délire à lui
c'était d'imiter le bruit des fourmis et
des feuilles mais je siégerai comment
vous avez fait vous avez réussi à rester
sérieux sur toute la séquence
respect c'est parti
[Musique]
le canada peut refaire un peu les bruits
d'animaux
[Applaudissements]
l'idée c'est un médecin c'est qui celle
où il parle quand même ça ça veut dire
il ya une mousse qui lui parle de ses
ouailles de minutes jarry et la
domination toi je défie suis né avec un
chèque à bourdon le mec il est connu
dans le monde entier parce qu'il avait
les la mouche qui pète c'est comme des
petits séjours dans la rue comme vous le
savez alors d'aller poser une question
aux français voilà mais au dernier
moment là je leur compassion qui
m'intéresse moi elle a du coup ça a créé
des petits moments de malaise qui leur
sont trop payés alors c'est pour la
caméra est footballeur
elle va ça vous dérange vous nous dire
ça parce caméra 3 1 je suis avec jeanine
jeanine qui bique raf des gros yeux doux
en bas de son immeuble dans 93 autrement
dit qui dealent du cannabis
cora
alors vous pensez que les footballeurs
sont trop payés réponse à venir ça du
tout juste comme ça jeudi au mali pour
la séquence c'est beaucoup tu me dis que
je suis avec moi dis moi dis qu'ils
sortent de la pharmacie et qui traitent
ces troubles de l'érection
c'est pas cool
aujourd'hui si on regarde tout le monde
non non ça vous dérange vous répondre à
ça parce que maman je suis avec béatrice
qui bique rave des gros yeux doux en bas
de son immeuble dans le 93 autrement dit
qu'il dit du cannabis je vous demander
si vous pensez que les footballeurs sont
trop payés que vous appelez comment
l'école je suis avec donald trump
bonjour alors en gros c'est donc savoir
si on pensait que footballeur son propre
pays on a tous comme ça au jour en
allemagne pour la séquence
je suis avec pascal pascal qui sort de
la pharmacie et qu'il a décidé de
traiter ces problèmes d'érection ça les
problèmes d'érection c'est de la merde
en gros savoir s'il pensait que le bio
est accessible pour les français daniel
je suis avec daniel et sérieuse de
sextoys pour l'émission m6 boutique quoi
tant dans son propre pays mon couteau
oui quel est votre colloque france soir
je suis avec françois alias francs
francs la taloche ancien skinhead du
milieu parisien
oui je pense effectivement que les
footballeurs sur beaucoup tant payé
alors en gros je vais demander si tu
penses que déjà les footballeurs sont
trop payés c'est bon tu me dis comment
tim ducan ces bois et sur mathias je
suis avec marouane marouane qui vient de
recevoir ces pilules d'agrandissement du
pénis
[Applaudissements]
et note nicole inquiète rôle derrière ce
que ça c'est qu'ici nous tous une
autorisation de diffusion donc ils sont
tous ok et franchement les français sont
formidables
c'est vraiment des à merci et merci
[Applaudissements]